SIERRA: So, like many of you, we at Why It
Matters have been watching the news coming
out of Afghanistan. The United States 20-year
war has come to an end, the government we
attempted to build there has failed, and the
Taliban has retaken the country with breathtaking
speed. The footage is haunting - images of
people desperately clinging to an airplane
as it takes off from Kabul, women expressing
fear of the new regime. For many of us it
s a time of reckoning, and of soul-searching
about what went wrong. The debate is going
to continue for years to come, but one thing
is certain, we have to try to learn the right
lessons from Afghanistan. So, in an effort
to start learning those lessons, we thought
we would do something different this week.
Usually on the show we feature several guests
with differing opinions. We think that s important.
But today we are just going to have one guest,
and he s my boss, Richard Haass, the President
of the Council on Foreign Relations. We spoke
on zoom, and the team decided to release the
conversation with minimal editing. The views
you will hear are his own. We spoke to him
because he has spent four decades studying
and advising on Afghanistan, serving under
four presidents. He was in the room when many
of the most important early decisions about
the Afghanistan War were debated and shaped.
There s a lot on his resume, but here are
a few things you should know. He was in the
State Department in the 1980s when the Reagan
Administration attempted to counter the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan. He later worked at
the National Security Council under the first
President Bush, where he attempted to implement
a post-Soviet policy for the country. Most
importantly, he was the head of policy planning
for the State Department under the second
President Bush when 9/11 occurred, and became
the U.S. Coordinator for the future of Afghanistan
in the period that followed. He left the Bush
administration in 2003 to become the President
of CFR. I m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is
Why It Matters. Today, Richard Haass on the
Afghanistan War.
SIERRA: Welcome to the show, Richard Haass.
So, it's quite a timeline you've had. An incredible
amount of experience this whole way. So to
dive into some of these pieces, you know let's
go back a bit. Based on the reality at the
time, do you think we were right to go into
Afghanistan?
HAASS: We were 100% right to go into it, and,
we didn't want to do it. We gave the Taliban
a choice. The Taliban made the wrong choice,
a fateful choice for them. 3,000 people have
died in our country in a day. But also the
precedent. We thought it was critical to set
the international norm that we wouldn't distinguish
between terrorists and those who supported
them. So I think that was 100% right. We hadn't
thought through, a whole lot, what we would
do afterwards. We didn't know how long this
would take. But then again I think we made
the right decision to help the Afghans forge
their own government. The feeling was if we
did too much, it would lack legitimacy. We
thought it was important to come up with an
Afghan leader, also who was Pashtun, not from
one of the northern tribes. And Hamid Karzai
emerged as that person. That was the only
thing that was clear. After that, and I expect
we'll talk about it, there wasn't a clear
plan and there wasn't consensus within the
administration over what ought to be the trajectory
of US policy. How ambitious should we be?
What was our definition of success at that
point? And that's where things began to break
down.
SIERRA: I mean, I remember this early phase
a bit. You know, how effective were we at
diminishing the terrorist threat to the United
States? Because I remember, at the time, everyone
was talking about the War on Terror.
HAASS: Well, the War on Terror became an important
part of American foreign policy. But the Afghan
dimension of it had been dramatically reduced.
And the War on Terror became a global preoccupation,
particularly in parts of the Middle East and
Africa, because that's where various cells
of terrorists set up shop. And what we discovered,
groups like Al-Qaeda and others, they were
global. They had access to money. They had
access to guns. They had access to people.
And that phase of American foreign policy
began 20-odd years ago, and it's still happening.
It's still taking place, largely but not exclusively,
in the Middle East and Africa. It's also taking
place in parts of Asia. And, to me, it's open-ended.
I mean, here we are, we're meeting at a time
we're battling a disease. I think there's
some parallels. There's an open-ended quality.
You don't eliminate terrorism anymore than
you eliminate a virus. These are now baked
into the world of the 21st century. So I think
it's an open-ended challenge, though for a
moment, where it had come to us most painfully
and vividly, was out of Afghanistan. I should
be clear for those who don't know, the history
of that is where the terrorists involved in
9/11 had been trained, where they had gotten
support. They weren't Afghans, most of them
were from Saudi Arabia and elsewhere in the
Middle East. But this is where they had been
supported. This is where things were organized.
This is where Osama Bin Laden was hanging
out. But with the removal of the Taliban pushing
the Al-Qaeda out and the Taliban out, most
of whom went to Pakistan, Afghanistan was
no longer the epicenter of world terrorism.
It essentially had dispersed.
SIERRA: So, how did our reason for being in
Afghanistan change through the years? You
know, what were the competing views on what
should be done after the initial phase?
HAASS: It's the most important question and
I'm glad you asked it. Because it's something
that comes back to haunt us in many ways.
So we had successfully worked with our Afghan
partners, removed the old authority, we had
helped bring about a new authority, led by
Mr. Karzai. And then the question was, well
what do you do at that point? They weren't
strong. The feeling was we couldn't just leave
them to be, because we knew that the Taliban
had moved to Pakistan. But the question was,
how do we stand them up? How do we build them
up so they could be something approximating
a normal country? We weren't talking about
democracy at this point, we were talking about
building up the capacity of this post-Taliban
government so they could police their borders.
And they could police their country so that
terrorists would not once again use Afghanistan
as a piece of real estate. And the debates
we had within the Bush Administration, again
this is Bush 43, and I remember them painfully
and vividly was how, to put it bluntly how
ambitious should we be? And one of the phrases
that's commonly now booted about is nation
building. And what that really is, is capacity
building. What kind of capacities or sometimes
called state building ought we to try to bring
about? And what I was proposing was that the
United States and other international forces
would come to Afghanistan temporarily. We
already had some. We would stay there temporarily
and perform two functions. One was we would
help the new government consolidate authority
over Afghan real estate, it's a large country.
And secondly, we would help develop, train,
a force. Wasn't clear how national it would
be as opposed to regional, but we would help
stand up an Afghan army. All I can say is
there was remarkably little enthusiasm within
the US government for doing it, remarkably
little. I'm used to being unsuccessful in
my policy proposals, but even in my career
of unsuccessful attempts to influence policy
this stood out. It was one of the most painful
national security meetings I had ever attended.
There just wasn't enthusiasm. If I had to
boil it down Gabrielle, I would say it reflected
two things. One was pretty legitimate, which
was why do we wanna get ambitious in Afghanistan?
This is a country with little tradition of
a strong central government. It's very tribal,
it's regional. This is just the wrong place
for us to get ambitious. And I think that
was a legitimate concern. The other concern,
less legitimate, is there was much more excitement
about getting involved more in other parts
of the world i.e. Iraq. And the feeling was
that that was a place where if we did invest
we would have more to show for it. Iraq was
a potential democracy. Iraq was a model that
other Arab countries might emulate. Afghanistan
was seen as an isolated one-off. So it was
not only seen as a poor prospect, which again
I think was a legitimate concern, it was seen
as a poor investment. What I said was we had
a window, the Taliban had been routed, our
authority was really high. We needed to build
up authority. You can't remove an authority
and then not try to put something in its place.
And for those who question me on that I have
one word for you, Libya. Under the Obama presidency,
the United States went in and removed Gaddafi
and never put anything in his place and Libya
became a failed state. And what we learned
in some cases is that bad situations can get
worse. So my view on Afghanistan, I didn't
have that example at the time, was to say
we've gotta try to do something. Let's not
get overly ambitious, but let's also not get
under ambitious. We have a moment here. And
I thought we would have significant international
help, and I said for a short time we could
do this, but there was just simply no enthusiasm
for it. And if you look at the history, what
happened subsequently is the rate of if you
will nation building or capacity building
or army building in Afghanistan, it was incredibly
slow, glacial may be an exaggeration but not
too much of one. Meanwhile, this was not happening
in isolation. What else was happening? So
we were building up the Afghans at I think
a terribly slow rate, but the Taliban was
rebuilding and reconstituting at a pretty
good clip.
SIERRA: Right.
HAASS: Why? Because they had set up shop in
Pakistan. And whereas initially we had gone
to the Pakistanis, it turned out one of the
senior members of the Pakistani government
had been in Washington on 9/11. And we read
them the Riot Act that the State Department,
Rich Armitage, the deputy secretary. And initially
the Pakistanis cleaned up their act, but over
time things kind of went back to business
as usual. And you had the Taliban openly operating
out of Pakistani cities. And the North-West
Frontier Province of Pakistan became a giant
sanctuary for the Taliban. And one of the
things history says, it's very hard to prevail
in a civil war if one of the parties has access
to a cross-border sanctuary. Which is exactly
what happened. So we had two dynamics, a very
slow dynamic of building up government capacity,
and a rather healthy dynamic or fast dynamic,
which was unhealthy, of the Taliban reconstituting
itself. In part because the US military had
failed to stop them from escaping, and then
we kind of took our eye off the ball and Pakistan
went ahead and allowed the Taliban to regroup
and rebuild. So that's where we ended up.
By then, I had left government years before
in the summer of 2003 to take my current job.
But this is what happened, over the course
of the Bush years. And then by the time the
Obama administration got in then the Taliban
had resumed all sorts of efforts within Afghanistan.
The situation was beginning to deteriorate,
and by then we made the fateful decision to
dramatically increase American forces. And
the problem with surging US forces is one,
by then we clearly had overstayed our welcome
in Afghanistan. Two, as I said we had allowed
the Taliban to rebuild. And three, the fact
that we were surging forces increasingly involved
in combat against a reconstituted Taliban
meant that US casualties went way up and the
cost of the war in every definition of the
word cost went way up. So Afghanistan went
from being the good war to simply the second
bad war. And that happened during the time
of the Obama administration.
SIERRA: So, you testified before The Senate
Foreign Relations Committee and expressed
your skepticism that the surge in Afghanistan
was a good choice. I think at the time, you
said, that we may have to accept a situation
that is just good enough in Afghanistan.
HAASS: The surge was a kind of an attempt
to be decisive, in a situation I didn't think
we could be decisive. That it wasn't gonna
end in military victory, it wasn't gonna bring
about the Taliban yelling uncle for peace.
So, I favored over the years, was something
more modest. The idea of Afghanistan good
enough? or Iraq, good enough? I actually think
is an important one. Americans tend to see
situations as problems, and anytime one hears
the word "problem," one immediately expects
to see the word "solution." And the problem
with thinking of things as problems, now that
I've totally muddled it, is that lots of things
are really situations, and by definition,
situations cannot be solved with military
force or any other policies. At best, they
can be managed. Which often means not what
you can bring about, but what it is you can
avoid. I wanted to dial down our ambitions
and simply say, here's what we want, we want
to avoid a Taliban takeover of the major cities.
Can't stop the Taliban from making some inroads.
So, what we wanna focus on is a situation
we can help sustain at an affordable cost.
This argues against the surge. A surge was
looking for a decisive blow in a situation
where there simply was not a decisive blow.
I think we've gotta be modest about what we
ask military force to do. I have Colin Powell,
before he was Secretary of State, as you know,
he was a General, and he said, you know, military
force is good at destroying things. What military
force can do is create a context in which
other things can happen, but my own view is,
we often turn to it too often. But, look,
going back to your immediate question, yeah,
I traffic in ideas, like anybody else, I look
at history. I try to make sense of what's
going on. I offer recommendations, and whether
I'm in government or out of government. And,
you know, I've spent decades in government
and decades out of government. It's not only
that I'm wrong sometimes and perhaps right
sometimes, but also, you know, there's times
you get listened to and times you don't. And
it's just frustrating when the times, it's
not that you don't get listened to. It's on
those occasions where you might have been
more right than wrong, and the consequences
of what we did are really costly. Those are
the things that keep me up at night, and Afghanistan
falls into that bucket. There's things about
Afghanistan and we're seeing them play out
before us now, that if you're not frustrated
by them, if you're not made a little bit sick
by them, by what we're seeing, then you're
not paying attention.
SIERRA: I guess that brings me to a question
of does nation building ever work?
HAASS: Sure. I mean the most famous successes
are places like Germany and Japan after World
War II.
HAASS: These were defeated, then occupied
places. So the question you have to ask is
why did it work there? And you look at the
characteristics of these societies, highly
educated, highly homogenous, in many cases,
societies with strong national traditions
and so forth. None of these things were present
in Afghanistan. So again it was not a good
candidate, I get it. The question was, I didn't
see clear alternatives at that point. Now
I couldn't guarantee it would work. But I
thought it was worth a limited investment.
I didn't think it was high risk at that moment
because we had tremendous authority, we had
tremendous momentum, the Taliban were gone,
Al-Qaeda was gone. So I thought there was
a window. And my view was let's take advantage
of this window. Worse comes to worst it won't
work. Okay, then we can deal with the consequences
of that. But we were not willing to give it
I thought a serious try, and that set in motion
a situation where the government of Afghanistan
was never able to do what it needed to do.
We misguidedly took on an ever larger role.
So we became not just the nation builders
behind the scenes, we essentially became a
protagonist in their civil war. And that seemed
to me an escalation that was unwise. But I'm
worried here, that wars are always fought
three times. There's the question of whether
you fight a war, there's the fighting of the
war and then it's the lessons. And what worries
me a little bit about this is that we could
learn the wrong lessons. I don't think the
lesson ought to be that nation or state building
is always wrong, it's always destined to fail.
I think what we really need to think hard
about is what are the conditions which we
think are positive, and what are the techniques?
What have we learned about sequencing? What
have we learned about pacing? What have we
learned about how do we adjust for local culture
and history? And the reason this is so important,
we don't want to be doing everything ourselves
around the world. But there's dozens of governments
around the world we need to help, and particularly
in the Middle East, particularly in Central
America, particularly in Africa. And so we
had better learn some of the correct lessons
of nation building rather than to say well
it's never worth it, or it's never a good
idea. That seems to me we either live in a
world which is much more dangerous, or we
confront ourselves with having the United
States get involved directly in combat operations
in more places, and I sure don't want that.
SIERRA: I mean look, one of the things that
I can't help but think about is, you know,
the women, right. I mean, this is something
that has been told to us in the messaging
of why we were even still in Afghanistan,
the repression of women. And these women saw
a level of freedom, and now they saw this
chance disappearing. You know, you mention
culture, what responsibilities do we have
to a society and to a culture when we come
into a country and leave?
HAASS: You're asking big questions today,
and I'm not going to avoid your question,
but it's not an easy one. Look, this is one
of the fundamental debates in American foreign
policy. To what extent should American foreign
policy be about shaping and influencing the
external behavior of other countries? Essentially,
to what extent should American foreign policy
be about influencing the foreign policy of
others? And to what extent should what we
do in the world be about influencing the domestic
behavior, the nature of others? The problem
is with that, often our influence is limited.
Often we have other priorities. Maybe the
single most ambitious task you can imagine
you can set for yourself, is to try to change
the internal workings of another society,
particularly one with a long and deep culture.
So I take from this, yeah, we have values
here, but we've got to understand in some
cases the limits to our influence, that we
can't always translate our preferences. I
don't like this. I still remember a dinner
party where I made this argument about the
Middle East, and I was excoriated, I think
is not too strong of a word. Hammered, might
be another word by a prominent former policy
maker on the basis of, I was selling people
short in the Middle East. And I was actually
accused of a kind of racism, that not everybody
was ready for democracy. And I said I wasn't
making a statement about individuals. I was
making a statement about cultures and societies.
And you know, I'd studied enough anthropology
and sociology and enough about the Middle
East in particular where one had to be aware
of pre-conditions and resistance to certain
types of traditions. And I take that as simply,
I don't like it. I like the idea that everybody
in the Middle East would read the Federalist
Papers, an Arabic translation, and that people
in Afghanistan would be reading it in Dari
or whatever, but it's not necessarily going
to happen. So, I think we have to decide what
are the limits to our influence, what are
our priorities. What are those things that
American foreign policy is well suited to
do? What are those things that are, that are
a reach? We're about to have a clinic in that
in Afghanistan because look, I worry profoundly
about what's gonna happen, yes, to girls and
women, first and foremost, but really to Afghans
of any gender, and not just those who are
working with the government or with us, about
people who want to have a 21st century life.
I worry and wonder. And, I worry about what's
going on in other parts of the world. Afghanistan
is not unique in the sense of those kinds
of concerns, but we can't impose our preferences
on others. I think the best thing we can often
do is our example. And our example, by the
way, is not what it could and should be right
now. So, whether it's to take an example of
our democracy, or the example of our economy,
the example of, our physical health, our social
health. I mean, there's so many ways we can
make this a society worth admiring and emulating.
That might be the best way in many cases we
can spread our values, but I don't think we're
in a position. Look, we couldn't convince
Myanmar. Think about the discrepancy between
the power of the United States and the power
of Myanmar. We can't oust the military junta
that took over there. Doesn't that tell people
something? There's a limit to our influence
in the world. And you know, we may be on the
side of right and morals and virtue, but that's
not necessarily the way history plays out.
SIERRA: But it's such a fine line, isn't it,
between spreading and setting a good example,
and imposing?
HAASS: So, you're right. And I don't mean
to caricature. So there are things we can
do. And we can, through foreign aid, do certain
things, through sanctions, discourage certain
behaviors. Through educational opportunities
here, we can do things. But there's still
limits. If the Taliban wants to impose Sharia
Law, wants to make, wants to force women to
wear a niqab, full covering. I don't think
we're gonna be in a position to stop it. Now
we might say, "Well because of these things,
we're not gonna provide you with this or that
kind of aid." Or, okay, and they may simply
shrug their shoulders and say, "So be it,"
and they may be able to find the support they
need externally from other places, be it Pakistan
or China or Russia, who tend not to care about
such things and have other priorities. So
again, we can have a foreign policy in part
which tries to more directly promote certain
behaviors, certain norms, certain standards,
but let me ask you a question. Just say what
should we care most about in Afghanistan?
And the priority has been that it not become
a place where terrorists again operate out
of. That's got to be the single most important
thing. That, if you will, is a more classic
foreign policy interest. And as we showed
on 9/11, after 9/11, we have mechanisms to
act with if that standard is not met by the
Taliban. They may have internalized that lesson.
We'll see whether they have internalized that.
But no one is gonna launch an intervention
in Afghanistan over Sharia Law or the fact
that women are treated abominably, as bad
as that is. So, again, it's one of the reasons
I didn't want us to get to this point. It's
one of the reasons, that I favored the United
States maintaining a small presence in Afghanistan
not because it would mean peace, not because
it would lead to a military victory, but I
thought it would avoid some of the scenes
we're either seeing or are likely to see in
coming days, weeks, months, and years. And
that, to me, was a consideration, the fate
that would likely befall girls and women,
as well as men in Afghanistan.
SIERRA: Yeah. It just feels sometimes like
a very fair weather argument where, you know,
people have used that defense to stay in Afghanistan
in the past, and now we can get up and leave
and abandon everybody.
HAASS: Well, it will have consequences. You
know, I've disagreed with this president's
policy on Afghanistan, as you know, from what
I've said and what I've written. His argument
was that he was not prepared, as gut wrenching
as it is, to have American forces stay in
Afghanistan longer, potentially put themselves
in harm's way, in order to deal with the issues
you're raising. That it was one thing to deal
with Afghanistan as a terrorist haven. It's
something else to deal with it as a human
rights nightmare. And he was basically saying,
we will turn to diplomacy. Well quite honestly
diplomacy ain't gonna do a lot. Mr. Biden
had inherited a situation that was a kind
of cake and eat it situation. We had a small
military presence. Americans hadn't been doing
combat operations, I don't know what, for
six, seven, eight years now. I've lost count.
Hadn't had a combat fatality for a year and
a half. That we had managed to get to a point
where the benefits and the costs were not
out of line, and one of the benefits are the
issues you've raised, the quality of life
in particular for Afghan girls and women.
The president wasn't willing to take the risk
that the costs of presence would go up. He
obviously didn't want to face the decision
of having to increase US forces if the security
situation deteriorated, so he's essentially
initiated a policy that's brought about a
truly, I think a set of terrible outcomes.
And my guess is he would say, "I don't like
these outcomes anymore than you did. I was
just not willing to take the risk of what
the price would be of our staying." And look,
I'm not gonna sit here and say that's not
a legitimate set of concerns. I actually think
there's legitimate debate, not over the way
the withdrawal was designed and implemented.
That was terrible. But I think there is a
legitimate debate, about whether the agreement
signed by the Trump administration in February
of 2020.I think that was a terrible agreement,
to get us out and undercut the government,
it virtually asked nothing of the Taliban.
I was the US Envoy to the Northern Ireland
peace talks. We asked much more of the provisional
IRA in Northern Ireland than we ever asked
of the Taliban. Just saying. We demanded a
cease fire. We demanded they give up their
arms. We didn't either with the Taliban. The
Taliban got off so, so, so easily. This was
not a peace agreement. This was an American
withdrawal agreement. I thought the Trump
administration was dead wrong to do it. I
thought Mr. Biden, who's had no trouble distancing
himself from other things he inherited from
Mr. Trump on Iran, on climate change, on the
World Health Organization, should have distanced
himself from this, but he didn't. Essentially,
followed it.
SIERRA: But public opinion, everyone wanted,
you know, mostly did want to get out, right?
HAASS: Well I didn't see a lot of intensity.
Sure, if you ask people, do you want to get
out, they'll probably say they want to get
out of most places. Unless I missed it, most
people, when they ask people, why did you
vote the way you voted in November '20 I didn't
notice people saying Afghanistan.
SIERRA: Right, right.
HAASS: The protests we had in, '20 and '21
were about race issues, policing issues. We're
not about Afghanistan. This was not the Vietnam
War.
SIERRA: Yeah.
HAASS: So, you know, again, policy is not
necessarily made on the idea of popularity.
That's why we don't have referendums every
day in this country. Well, we have a representative
government, where leaders make tough decisions.
The fact that Americans may today say they
like the fact we're out, well how much would
they like it if in a couple years we face
problems of terrorism? How much will they
like it if human rights atrocities happen?
I don't think you can conduct foreign policy
on the basis of short-term popularity.
SIERRA: I'm sure you don't love that people
neglect foreign policy a bit in their day-to-day
decisions and their voting, and then focus
on this type of thing.
HAASS: Look, it is, what it is, what it is.
And I wish there were more consistent interest
in the world, particularly since we're living
in a world. Coming back to the theme of this
podcast you host. You don't have to look very
far to see how the world matters. We're up
against the 20th anniversary of 9/11. Where
3,000 people died here in a day. We've been
talking about on your show, COVID. More than
600,000 Americans already have lost their
lives from a disease that broke out in Wuhan,
China, however it broke out. We are dealing
with the growing terrible effects of climate
change, which is, if you will, the cumulative
effect of activity, everywhere. What we put
in cyberspace now is no longer safe. We can't
even protect our own cyberspace from other
people putting things in there we don't want.
HAASS: So, people may not be that interested
in the world, but the world's interested in
us. That seems to me simply a fact of life.
And the reason foreign policy's so important
is what we do and don't do have, in turn an
impact on the world. There's a loop here.
The world influences us. We can influence
the world. And I think what's interesting
about Afghanistan, if you look at the last
20 years, I think there's been, moments, some
moments we got it right, I think after, again,
9/11, I think we got it initially right. I
think along the ways, we've done too little
and we've done too much. You almost, I almost,
wish you'd invited Goldilocks on your show
instead of me.
SIERRA: Ah, you know, she was so busy today.
I am sorry about that.
HAASS: Yeah, she tends to be overbooked.
SIERRA: Yeah, you know. Yeah.
HAASS: That Goldie, she just doesn't say no.
It's too bad.
SIERRA: A real people pleaser.
HAASS: But, if you look at the history of
the last 20 years, you could almost form two
columns, the times we have overreached in
Afghanistan, and the times we have under-reached.
And the last couple of, I'd say the last 18
months, there's been a lot of under-reaching.
What I was talking about, I think, after,
right after 9/11, early on in 2001, 2, 3,
I think we under-reached in some of the nation-building.
Controversial, I get it. But clearly with
the surge and other things, we overreached.
We put too many forces, but that's the kind
of conversation we need. I think it's important
to come away with the right lessons. The only
thing worse than making mistakes is not learning
from them.
SIERRA: Well, on that note, Richard Haass,
thank you for joining us on Why It Matters
today.
HAASS: Always a pleasure. Good to see you.
SIERRA: Good to see you as well.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes. Have a
question or some feedback? Just feel like
saying hi? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we d love it if you
could leave us a review. Ideally a good one,
the more stars the better. It really does
help us get noticed. Why It Matters is a production
of the Council on Foreign Relations. The show
is created and produced by Asher Ross, Jeremy
Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert
is our assistant podcast producer. Sophie
Yass is our summer intern. Robert McMahon
is our Managing Editor, and Doug Halsey is
our Chief Digital Officer. Original music
is composed by Ceiri Torjussen. Special thanks
go to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke. For Why
It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra signing
off. See you soon!